we know in our bones this one is more
consequential
and this is the most important election
in the history of our country
[Music]
from bloomberg quick take i'm ever white
welcome to the final episode of the most
important election ever after three and
a half years of trump which have
included an immigration scandal
a trade war and impeachment three
supreme court not confirmations
a worldwide pandemic and a summer of
protests the big day is finally here
election day 2020 here to discuss the
2020 election season from start to
finish
preview tonight's results and potential
outcomes and explain why it's been the
most important election ever
is madison mills bloomberg quick take
journalists covering politics
and culture and also the once the host
of this show maddie thanks for joining
us again on the most important election
ever welcome back
thank you so much for having me ever how
are you i'm great i'm great um
ready for ready for the big day to jump
off first things first maddie
oh sorry about that but first things
first have you voted yet maddie
yes very important question everek it's
uh it feels like this day has been going
on for weeks because of all of the early
voting right
it's like is it november 3rd or has it
been going on for weeks
but um i was lucky to be able to send in
an absentee ballot for
my hometown in florida i spent most of
the year living there with my mom during
the pandemic
so it was nice to be able to do that but
what about you were you able to vote are
you going in person today
uh no i actually early voted in harlem
on friday on 135th street where there
was a lovely spread of free waffles for
the voters so
i took care of both my political and and
culinary needs at the same time
i love to hear a political and culinary
combo that's fantastic
we love christina and just to ask where
were you
in 2016
yeah so it's really interesting and kind
of shocking to think that four years
have passed i was having a lot of
nostalgic feelings when i woke up this
morning
uh but in 2016 it was my first year out
of college and i was working at the
times
on their live video team so i was doing
12
hours of live video content to cover uh
the 2016 results and i just remember
that feeling
of there's this feeling when you're a
journalist and news is breaking that i'm
sure you resonate with ev
when it's just this like adrenaline rush
that keeps you awake and we were up for
72 hours covering this thing and i'm
anticipating a very similar setting this
time around just because
as we know the chances of having a
result tonight are kind of slim
so i'm thinking that um i'll also be
awake for
at least 72 hours the next few days
it's the ultimate natural high election
results who who wouldn't love exactly
and for our viewers we'll be the
thousandth people to tell you please get
out there and vote
make sure your voices are heard today um
i can't impressify you the importance of
it but
matty let's do a quick stage setter
today is the last day of the 2020
general election season
um let's let's give us a quick summary
joe biden announced his candidacy back
in april 2019
while trump kicked off his reelection
campaign in june of 2019.
what were those first days like compared
to today
yeah it's such a great question everek
because it does feel like
the campaign for 2020 has been going on
for a lifetime
this has we've seen the highest number
of candidates
ever running for office uh during this
election
when biden made his announcement there
was originally a lot of enthusiasm
around him running
a lot of people hoped that he'd run in
2016 and of course he did not make that
decision
but there was a lot of enthusiasm when
he first announced however
that was quickly sort of quelled by the
number of people who
started to get huge fan bases folks like
andrew yang
pete buddha judge senator elizabeth
warren of course senator bernie sanders
folks who
were familiar names um but we had these
sort of like star
front runners emerge during the 2020
election
um and again that just sort of threw off
the biden camp they didn't necessarily
anticipate these sort of um internet fan
bases in particular
uh when i think about andrew yain's
campaign i just think about kind of the
viral high that his campaign was able to
keep up
the entire race uh and and so biden
biden was originally had a lot of that
momentum that was
uh sort of sort of quelled as other
candidates got more popular
president trump on the other hand when
this sort of all started
he was having a time of huge economic
prosperity which is his main
sort of message to his base is i'm going
to give you the economy that you need to
be able to succeed
and also back in february we saw the
impeachment trials come to an end
and that ended very positively for him
so it's interesting to think about that
moment in february where the trump
campaign was
extremely overjoyed with how things were
going again economic prosperity
the impeachment trials were over uh and
then
you know coronavirus was right around
the corner lurking and that
certainly had a huge impact on how the
president's campaign has been perceived
and of course how biden has been
perceived we saw him
at the north carolina primary doing
really well and then continuing that
momentum through super tuesday
but once coronavirus really took hold uh
that's when his campaign
really started to resonate with voters
so you mentioned a lot of of big
tentpole things there matty um
you mentioned at one point upwards of 25
people were running for the democratic
nomination
um you touched on it for a second but
how did the sheer number of people on
the democratic side
shape the 2020 race um going forward
it's such a great question evereck uh
a lot of campaign strategists felt like
this was
all over the place um in terms of kind
of the horse race of this election we
saw
in the iowa primary for example buddha
judge did extremely well
and then we saw biden really coming into
the background throughout the debates
because
he's not a star debater this is
something that um his campaign staff
have really had to work with him on
buddha judge on the other hand is an
incredible public speaker and that
really resonated with voters and heading
into the primaries a lot of democratic
strategists were looking even at a
bloomberg as someone who could
potentially
take on that role as a moderate option
compared to the president
uh and and strategists really wanted to
offer
democrats who were a little bit more in
the middle that that moderate option
because
of the sort of what moderates would call
the radical left
candidates of elizabeth warren and
bernie sanders
uh and so the division within the
democratic party
itself came into play very clearly among
these candidates who were all over the
map from
um moderate to far left uh thinkers so
it was really interesting to see that
play out and again just see each
candidate had like their week
in the spotlight it felt like um
throughout this race oh for sure um i
remember when we were covering it just
looking at the the sheer number and
seeing all the different faces that were
on that
debate stage when we first started um it
seems like the democrats
um have kind of come from branching out
into one sort of
uh message while trump essentially ran
unopposed on the gop
side of matty could you explain what
that says about the republican party in
2020
right i think everett it's kind of
similar to the
message that we've seen from republican
senators heading into the down the
ballot races today
um there's a lot of enthusiasm on the
right for president trump and those
voters have
made their decision in 2016 we saw a lot
of
undecided voters heading into election
day i think something like 15
of voters uh asked two weeks before the
election did not have
their candidates selected um and then a
lot of those
voters went for trump and that's part of
the reason why some of that polling
uh was not able to predict a trump win
as clearly as voters would have liked
but
that's not the case in 2020 we've seen
president trump
consistently polling well with his base
and so the gop isn't
really incentivized to bring forward a
challenger to him because
uh the folks who've already decided that
they're voting for trump
are staying with trump um and we've seen
that throughout the coronavirus pandemic
too
uh the president really had an
opportunity to shift his messaging
around coven 19 after he
uh survived the virus and he opted not
to do that
um and that's an opportunity where a lot
of strategists i've spoken to
said that trump could have used his
language around his own battle with
kovid to get a lot of swing voters
over to his side with a message of we're
gonna fix this virus we're gonna fix the
economy
and he doubled down on the idea that the
virus isn't something to worry about
which
really again resonates with his base of
people who've already made that decision
to stick with trump and and they're not
going to change their minds
um so it seems like there's a much
different narrative
going forward right now for for the
trump side and for the blind side
actually um
it seems like biden similar to hillary
had a bit of a lead over trump um going
into today but this time it seems like
there's more of a positive tenor around
biden's campaign
versus hillary's um how has this
election
differed from 2016 in terms of narrative
with regards to that
it's it's a great question everec i
think one of the biggest
things that i'm hearing from pollsters
i've spoken with is that
um in 2016 a lot of voters didn't like
either candidate
and it's kind of the exact opposite now
like i was just saying
trump's base loves him uh and voters
love biden as well and it's very
different from the reaction
that hillary clinton had where a lot of
voters were
begrudgingly voting for her as an option
uh that wasn't trump
now we're seeing that uh pres or i'm
sorry former vice president biden has a
very
high favorability rating among voters
so that makes a huge impact in his
ability to
get people to not only vote today but
vote early we saw
over 95 million people send in their
ballots early this election cycle
which is record-breaking in so many ways
more people have already voted in the
state of texas
than voted in all of 2016 and that was
before
november 3rd so we're seeing a lot of
energy
surrounding today's election and that's
another thing that's very different from
2016.
people on both sides are energized to uh
i was reading in a bloomberg article
this morning that
democrats are energized to vote trump
out and republicans are energized to
vote trump in
and both of those juxtaposing ideas are
really getting people
excited and getting them to vote early
and vote today as well
great point that about the enthusiasm
i'm sure
there are tons of people out there right
now who are voting and
and wondering what their vote is going
to mean um come the the results
um maddie we we've seen that there are
tons of different um potential roads
that this election can take could you
describe
some of the potential outcomes of
today's election um could we be looking
at an election week or
an election month as opposed to an
election day
there are so many variables here i was
trying to build out a decision tree
earlier today of
which swing states trump could win or
lose and how that impacts the election
uh so there there are a lot of variables
here but um
the the ones that i'm mainly focused on
are the swing states uh specifically
the states in the great lakes area that
surprisingly
went trump in 2016 we saw michigan
going to trump with just 80 000 votes
for example
those three great lakes states are
really important for the biden campaign
if he's able to get those
he'll feel very confident tonight also
if either camp gets florida that's 29
electoral votes
that's going to be huge we're also
looking at texas
like i mentioned earlier voter turnout
has been unprecedented in texas this
election
i spoke with our washington
correspondent yesterday who i i
basically said
is that good for trump or bad and it was
really interesting the response i got
was that
in big cities in texas like houston
voter turnout
is higher than ever but it's also higher
than ever in
sort of republican-leaning um rural
areas so
uh both sides again are incredibly
energized to vote now there's also the
chance
that we could get a tie uh there is an
even number of electoral
college voters in this country so it's
possible to get a tie it's
pretty unlikely uh but but that is an
option and then of course the third
option is just that states like
pennsylvania michigan wisconsin all
three of them
were not able to start counting those
mail-in ballots
until today that's very different from a
state like florida that's
extremely used to mail-in voting because
of hurricanes and the elderly population
these states are going to be very behind
on their voting so
that could lead to a red mirage of sorts
where
the voters who are going in person today
are more likely to be republican leaning
because of trump's rhetoric around
the fraudulence of mail-in voting which
we know to not be true
but because of that there could be this
feeling that trump is winning as
uh in-person votes are being counted
today and while we wait for those
early mail-in votes to be counted so
those are
uh just a few of the many variables that
we have heading into tonight everek
wow that's a lot of different ways that
this could play out and i'm sure that
that our our viewers know the the the
sheer amount of different states that
could
swing the election but i'm i'm i wonder
what role could congress and the the
supreme court play
if there are contested results i know
amy coney barrett's confirmation
has worried some progressives and people
on the left but what what could happen
if there is no no clear result
today maddie right there is still the
chance everett
everett speaking on amy comany barrett
that she does
recuse herself from a decision if there
is a tie because
of the timeline that she was brought in
to the supreme court
she was unclear on that during her
confirmation hearings but it is a
possibility that she
chooses to recuse herself because of the
timeline uh
if if there's a tie the house of
representatives
is going to play a very key role in
deciding this election
but what's also interesting about that
is the same issues that we're having
with the presidential race we're going
to have on down the ballot races they're
also going to have issues with counting
mail-in votes and
tallying uh these votes as they come in
so we may not have a clear answer on
what congress looks like tonight either
and i think that that's something that
people aren't necessarily thinking about
is this idea that oh well if there's a
tie it'll go to congress or the supreme
court but
we're not gonna have a lot of clarity on
either of those branches either
um because of what i just mentioned so i
know that's not the most
soothing thing to hear as we have all of
these questions but
uh i i think that there's i think if we
do get to a tie which is unlikely
uh there are going to be a lot of a lot
of
bigger questions that come from that now
i do think there's a strong chance that
president trump refutes the results of
the election and that's something i i
think is pretty likely that we'll see
because again even at his route his most
recent rally last night in michigan he
was laying the groundwork for
uh losing states like pennsylvania and
michigan saying things like well the
mail in boating could
could be fraudulent so i do think it's
very possible that we see
another bush v gore situation play out
after this
depending on how those results go and
then depending on how trump and biden
respond
so you're saying we actually could
definitely see an election week or maybe
even election month depending on how
these results trickle in going forward
um which is for many of our viewers
probably not what they want to hear but
we will absolutely be be keeping you
abreast of um
what happens going through the night um
we're going to close out soon soon
maddie but i wanted to go back to the
polls you said that
the polls got some really bad pr in
2016. why is 2020 any different
right evric it's a question on
everyone's mind it's something i've
certainly thought about a lot while
covering this election
uh in the past couple of weeks we've
seen
throughout october that biden has been
at least eight percentage points ahead
of trump in
most of the predominant polls but a lot
of people say well i don't trust polls
anymore because of what happened in
2016.
the good thing is that pollsters really
saw
those clear mistakes basically the pr
nightmare that
the polls suffered in 2016 made them
change
right so one thing that i found really
interesting is that
polls weight different groups based on
how much those groups are slated to
impact the election
so in 2016 for example pollsters
weren't as sure of this group of
uneducated or i'm sorry
non-college-educated white voters coming
out for trump it wasn't as clear then
that that group of people was going to
come out in droves for president trump
pollsters know that now they know that
this group is extremely energized for
trump
and so they're weighting the information
they're getting from that group of
voters very
heavily when they gather this data uh so
that's
that's one thing that's really helped us
feel a little bit more confident in
these polls
also it's important to remember that the
national polls in 2016
were not wrong um hillary was
consistently pulling
behind trump up and down throughout
october again we had
the james comey situation we had her
emails she had a lot of october
surprises that put her behind trump in
the
national polls it's really those state
polls where we saw errors in 2016
and all of those places have really
worked to
ensure that they don't make that mistake
again so we'll just have to see
how that shakes out tonight and we will
be
watching the polls watching the results
come in um
and we're just excited to to see what
happens but
um we're gonna wrap up shortly matty
lastly
our biggest question the reason we're
all here for the last time
why is the 2020 race the most important
election ever
right evric i think that more than ever
every single voter in this country
is experiencing the trauma of
coronavirus at the same time this is
something that people are feeling
every single day they're working from
home they're not sure how to send their
kids to school
they're staying inside so this is
something that's impacting everyone
we're seeing
eight million people in this country
slip below the poverty line
people need help they need help from the
federal government they
want to have an economic recovery that
they can rely on
and this is something that i think is
really energizing voters
also we're coming off a summer of
protests in all 50 states in support of
the black lives matter movement
which has really been on the hearts and
minds of voters we've never had protests
hit
every single state before so this is
unprecedented
uh in terms of just the multitude of
events that
every voter in this country has
experienced uh in 2020
and i think that those factors are
really why we're seeing
such unprecedented numbers of people
voting early
um but what do you think every why why
is this the most important election ever
to you
um i'd say much of the same um as a
black man
and living in this country it's it's
difficult to see what's happened
over the last six months and not feel
some sort of call to action
so for me the the reason that's this
most important election ever is because
there are so many people like me who
look like me who cannot have their
voices heard
so i want to be able to to
to make sure that what i'm impressing on
the people that i speak to
is that important um you know
there are so many different issues that
are circling the united states right now
whether it's immigration
the economy covid um the health care
the trade war um all of these things
that happened
over the last ten years the last three
and a half years that we have to deal
with
um and you know the we're at a unique
place in history where technology
um society have all just converged in
different ways and we have
a lot of work to do and that's why 2020
is the most important election ever to
me
but absolutely ever yes that was great
yes yes and that's a great place to wrap
it up
um i just want to thank maddie mills for
joining me today to preview tonight's
election results
thank you to all of our guests for
taking the time to talk to us
and thank you the viewers for tuning in
with us these last seven weeks
i'll remind you once more if you haven't
please please please go vote it takes
just a few minutes to make your voice
heard
in the most important election ever i'm
ever white
for bloomberg quick take thanks for
joining us guys